um i want to start with congratulations
on the movie i thought you guys did such
a great job with the material um
uh i like starting with a a a curve ball
at the beginning so for both of you if
someone has actually never seen anything
you've worked on before uh what is the
first thing you want them watching and
why
wow
uh
i think for me
oh boy that's a bit of a toss-up
probably apollo 13 at the end of the day
i i think i think i i you know i gave a
lot of myself to it there was a lot of
innovation um and um you know and and
and that was a really important project
in my life i almost went with rush a
movie i'm very proud of um and um and i
look and i'm i you know i know we're
doing an interview about about uh 13
lives uh i'm you know i had a great
experience and and i was able to
reflect a lot on myself what i admire
about people what i aspire to as a
culture uh you know uh through the movie
so
you know that that so we'll uh when i
get a little more objectivity maybe that
could go high on the list as well and
for me because you know like in many
ways you know 13 lives is pretty much
similar to the kind of films that i make
as a producer because i like to make
films that say something about the state
of the world that we live in you know
whether it be from real events real
people characters and they're not
necessarily the easy questions either
but the thing is that they really are
things that make you understand and
think about where we are and this film
you know when ron asked me to be you
know part of it i was so touched because
what he said was that you know like um
you know this is during the pandemic it
was like you know june of 2020 and he
said you know the world is you know
going through some really tough times
you know both pandemic wise and social
politically and you know this story that
really happened it's just such a
positive story and it shows that when we
can come together without you know
having all these
crazy divisions among ourselves we can
actually really achieve something
miraculous
and you know isn't that something that
we need to see nowadays in this day and
age and i was like wow
yeah i i you know i was so completely
sold because it is so true that we need
this kind of statement nowadays one of
the things that i commend you on uh is
that it felt like i was watching a
documentary rather than something that
was hollywoodized and can you both sort
of talk about the aesthetic you were
going for in terms of of exactly what i
just said which is it feels more like a
documentary well i've been directing
docs of late uh and of course imagine
entertainment is you know has a
documentary group that is really
inspiring and such great directors
working there telling amazing uh stories
and uh and the so
certainly i wanted to apply that that
kind of um you know that sort of
authenticity and and and even some of
the the shooting styles and editorial
styles that you can find in in in that
language but
but there's something that you can do
with scripted material
um
and versions of these events that you
just can't quite do in a documentary and
that is you know get that great acting
um you know create these scenes that
unfold in a way that allows an audience
to really feel like they're they're
right alongside
the you know these circumstances they're
they're uh they're bearing witness
uh they're they're really feeling it um
and uh and having a more visceral kind
of experience and i felt like the more i
learned about this story um the more i
felt like there was a lot of
entertainment value there and and um and
and a way to sort of look at this story
uh and personalize it that in in so that
you know that you know it
might inspire uh on an even on on on an
even more individual level well i mean
you know when i first joined the
the project you know like ron was
already giving me certain ideas of what
he wanted to do of course you know one
of the touchstones is apollo 13. but a
lot of it is that he wanted authenticity
and realism because these things happen
and we had a lot of access and it was
incredible because you know in our
production you know place in australia
there were just wall to wall
basically like details and specs and
designs and every little detail from the
costumes to the colors of things that
are basically underground
was like you know we really considered
every little moment of that and i think
that that was you know it was apparent
since day one when you know ron was
asking me to have a look at the script
that he really wanted something that as
he said that if a thai person watches it
that they may not even know necessarily
if it's actually like you know like done
by a typers or not because the accuracy
is incredibly high and you know that's
one of the reasons why you know ron
ashley asked me to be part of it and you
know i i hope i did an okay job
we're
we're getting good results thank you but
uh you know what
i've learned in in recent years
especially doing movies about real
events that um
if you as a production team can really
immerse yourself in the subject ahead of
time
that it just on some in sort of
intrinsic intuitive level you you you
you create something that's a little
more engrossing for the audience it's
just more detailed audiences are just
more and more sophisticated by the by
the week
and um and it's the reason why we had to
have so much thai language in the movie
because
i would demand that of a film that i was
seeing based on some true event like
this but as raymond was saying we we
have i what i like to do is put video
monitors up in the production uh
department uh and over by the food
because people tend to head over to
where to the kitchen uh and in various
other places and have on the loop you
know all the news footage i can find all
the documentaries that i can find all
the reef all the all the all the photo
resources up on the walls so that you're
as you're prepping the movie you
actually can stop and and look at an
image or see a scene unfold in on it
from uh you know from from the
television monitor and just say how does
that relate to this scene that we're
going to try to recreate and it just
brings so much more sort of authority to
people's
understanding of what the what the truth
is and the honesty around around the the
subject i will admit that um when i
first heard about what happened i was
amazed that the kids were able to swim
out after all of that you know after
what happened and it was only watching
the documentary that i learned i don't
want to say it for people that are going
to
thank you
watch the movie
but what a twist
yeah it was i had no idea
well it's a you know it's amazing and
there's and look there are all kinds of
acts of courage that are demonstrated in
the real event
and you know i selected a few to try to
underscore it's an amazing story this is
a story that just goes on and on and on
and and and you can keep looking at it
from different vantages and and it's all
it's all valid and i you know if people
are intrigued by this
i certainly hope they see our film uh
but you know our film is going to be
seen slightly through a different lens
than the documentaries anything else you
might see down the road that's going to
be its own perspective as well all all
all valid and all really interesting but
it there are there are so many instances
of people making difficult decisions
making sacrifices that takes courage
and that's heroic and the outcome was uh
gratefully uh something that everyone
can be proud of for the rest of their
lives uh something that i thought you
guys did a really good job with uh one
of the many things is the water
sequences were very claustrophobic
and obviously you need to really put the
act like basically can you talk a little
bit about filming the water sequences
and what the actors really had to go
through to make
what it looks like on screen well that
was a real analog situation i mean
they're just digital could not help us
very much there it could do a you know a
a a a few little things in terms of just
uh some some said extensions and and
cleaning up a few things and helping
with the visuals so that we could
actually you know
recognize that it was murky but still
still see enough of them and a few
little things like that but basically
there was there was no other way around
this than
then actors
getting in the tank and putting on the
gear and and going through those tight
tight spaces now what happened is that
the real rick stanton and jason malanson
two of the real heroes they were also
our technical advisors
and they were there to work with the
actors on their diving because cave
diving is a completely different
technique than than open water diving
that's one of the reasons that the navy
seals struggled a bit because they
simply weren't trained to and they
didn't have their their gear set up to
be able to navigate these type twists
and turns and so forth so once the
actors had been trained the eagle
mortenson came to me
and said
this is so specific
and now we understand how to do it i
really really hope you won't double me
and all the other actors raised their
hand and said we support not only
support vigo but we want to say the same
thing
you know on our behalf and i said that's
so tough on the schedule they said well
we'll we'll adjust our schedule we'll
work the extra hours we'll you know uh
schedule us so that you know we have a
day off from the first unit but we can
go to the dive unit
i mean they just really went the extra
mile to do it themselves now that
gave me as a director this possibility
of doing these long lingering shots
that would unfold and you'd recognize
without a cut or an edit in any kind
that oh that's that really is viggo
mortensen clearly that's that's colin
farrell that's joel ed christian and
it's just on a subliminal level
that connects the audience all the more
to the suspense and the drama and the
feeling that they're being transported
somewhere and isn't that what movies
really do uh you know for people is it's
it's immersive
and it transports us at its best and
that no need to stop i'm just gonna say
seriously congrats on the movie hope
it's a big hit for you guys thank you
for giving me your time thank you so
much good talking to you